bonsoir nicolas vous ont soir vous êtes
économiste essayiste vous publié aux
édition de l'observatoire ce livre
l'amour augmenter nos enfants et nos
amours 21e siècle on va en parler mais
d'abord on va parler de ce que l'on
vient de voir dans ce reportage
on y voit certains jeunes inquiets pour
leur avenir mais aussi on voit des
jeunes qui préparent activement leur
futur alors quel message voulez vous
leur adressez à ces jeunes que y aura
pas de génération sacrifiée que les
états et en particulier l'état français
met en place des dispositifs très
important de soutien aux jeunes on le
voit avec l'alternance l'année 2020 sera
une année qui sera pas trop mauvaise en
matière d'alternance je veux pas trop
m'avancer il est même possible qu'elle
soit assez bonne parce que les soutiens
qui ont été mis en place en france sont
des soutiens extrêmement forts qui
fonctionne bien qu'il faudra d'ailleurs
sans doute pérenniser après la crise je
vais pas passer surtout l'aider je vais
pas passer en revue tous les détails du
plan de relance mais il ya aussi des
aides à l'embauché pour les entreprises
bon et puis je pense que ce qu'il faut
que se disent les jeunes aussi c'est que
ce qu vide c'est un accélérateur de
mutation est en réalité un certain
nombre de ces mutations sont positives
regardez ce qu'on est en train de faire
dans le domaine de l'écologie on
accélère très fortement ce qu'on est en
train de faire dans le domaine de
l'urbanisme on est en train de rénover
de refaire les villes et s'il ya la
crise mais oui oui c'est lié à la crise
parce que la crise si on la prend bien
une crise c'est un drame mais c'est
comme dans la vie vous avez des drames
qui vous tombe dessus ce s'est jamais
bien c'est jamais bon mais une fois ses
larmes
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que nous
disent exactement ça vous construit et
il faut essayer de s'appuyer là dessus
pour faire des choses bien
si ce qu'on est en train de faire je
prenais l'exemple de l'écologie c'est
très spectaculaire 7
cette accélération qui me rend très
confiants et même dans le domaine de la
santé
on voit bien que en france on est en
train de faire un certain nombre de
choses de ségur de la santé c'est pas en
pure perte
et donc j'ai quand même envie de dire
aux jeunes au fond tous ces
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire vous en tirer les bénéfices
n'écoutez pas ceux qui vous disent on
vous laisse une dette on vous laisse un
monde atroce cela les écoutez pas voilà
on est en train de construire quelque
chose de nouveau ensemble
vous avez écrit un d'ailleurs une
tribune où vous avez l'expliqué un petit
peu tout ça pour dire qu'il faut en
finir avec le mythe de la génération
sacrifiée voilà on le voit c'était dans
l'express mais quand même
les jeunes aujourd'hui ce qui arrive cet
automne sur le marché du travail
ils vont quand même se confronter à des
difficultés qui sont bien sûr évidemment
cette crise cette récession que nous
avons connu cette année c'est la plus
forte depuis 80 ans
bon on a mis en place là encore des
dispositifs de soutien qui sont très
performants l'activité partielle ça
permet d'éviter une explosion du chômage
l insee vient nous le rappeler dans sa
note de conjoncture on a une
augmentation du chômage mais elle est
quand même pour l'instant à ses contenus
les prêts garantis par l'état les fameux
pg pour les entreprises ça permet
d'éviter un trop grand nombre de
faillites en quelque sorte on étale un
peu la crise dans le temps après il faut
bien voir que la sortie de cette crise
c'est pas une crise économique c'est une
crise sanitaire qui a des conséquences
économiques et donc est ce que fait le
gouvernement sur le plan économique et
très bien les dispositifs de soutien de
mars c'est bien le plan de relance en
partage complètement l'orientation qui
est plutôt axé sur l'attractivité de la
france et sur l'offre mais les jeunes
pour les formations qu'elle sait très
bien si on est gentil ya des choses car
la formation continue aussi faut pas
oublier mais simplement tout ceci va se
heurter au manque de confiance qui lui
même est liée aux problèmes sanitaires
c'est pour ça que le message que je
voudrais envoyer notamment que je fais
passer au gouvernement c'est la
meilleure politique économique
aujourd'hui c'est la politique sanitaire
autant je trouve que sur le plan
économique le gouvernement fait très
bien les choses
autant quand on regarde par exemple la
question des tests mais favières
l'organisation des tests en france c'est
invraisemblable ça ne va pas du tout et
ça a des conséquences économiques
je ne veux pas opposer le ministre de la
santé et ministre de l'économie mais la
désorganisation en matière de tests ça
peut faire en partie échoué le plan de
relance voyez ce que je veux dire si on
doit re confiné si on a encore notre les
problèmes dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec à la pandémie qui au
fond c'est catastrophique
regardez la moindre fréquentation des
commerces aujourd'hui ça commence à
avoir des conséquences très forte sur
les faillites
les fleuristes les petits commerçants
certains artisans on a ces très grandes
difficultés donc il faut absolument que
tant qu'on n'a pas encore de vaccin ou
de remèdes qu'on organise au mieux
la situation sanitaire en france est
pour l'instant on n'y est pas on parle
des jeunes ont parlé aussi des personnes
âgées que pensez vous de ce qu'ils
disent dans le sillage de des propos
très provocateur de nicolas bedos par
exemple que l'on sacrifie aujourd'hui
les jeunes pour sauver les vieux je suis
en total désaccord avec cette thèse
depuis le début déjà moi je ne fais pas
de comptabilité générationnel je
n'oppose pas les uns aux autres vous
savez en ce moment on a put on nous
traversons une situation très grave et
très difficile on a plutôt besoin d'être
rassemblée notre civilisation elle a
fait passer la vie humaine avant
l'économie je pense que c'est un choix
admirable c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que ça se
produit ça prouve d'ailleurs que notre
modernité elle est pas si matérialiste
qu'on a bien voulu le dire ce que l'on
voit aussi c'est que on a des jeunes
aujourd'hui qui sont touchés fortement
par le coronavirus alors il meurt pas
forcément mais ils peuvent avoir des
séquelles pendant très longtemps on a
des jeunes en réanimation
je n'aime pas cette idée qui consiste à
opposer les uns aux autres en revanche
ce que nous devons faire c'est mettre en
place des mesures barrières et mettre en
place un contrôle des mesures barrières
qui n'affecte pas l'économie regardez
les restaurants je suis très opposé à la
fermeture des restaurants je suis très
opposé à la fermeture systématique des
salles de sport je pense en revanche
c'est ce qu'ont commencé les fraudeurs
qui doivent renforcer les protocoles
sanitaires
l'exemple des salles de sport et est
très est très symptomatique
il faut rouvrir les salles de sport dans
les zones où elles ont été fermées c'est
le cas à paris mais en renfonçant les
protocoles sanitaires et en renforçant
les contrôles parce que cette façon de
faire de fermer certains secteurs elle
est très dommageable économiquement et
puis elle est très injuste parce que
ceux qui ont bien fait les choses ils
payent pour les autres oui elle est
difficile à expliquer quand on voit par
exemple que les enfants peuvent aller
aujourd'hui faire du sport en intérieur
par les parents enfin il ya beaucoup de
disques on le connaît parfaitement ce
sujet des adolescents à la maison et je
vois bien que le sport au collège ou au
lycée ne respectent pas forcément les
mesures barrières alors qu'elles sont
respectés en salle de sport vous avez
tout à fait raison à nicolas bouzou vous
ne vouliez pas opposer le ministre de la
santé le ministre de l'économie
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et bien tous
les deux se sont exprimés à l'occasion
de la conférence de presse olivier
ferrand a expliqué un certain nombre de
nouvelles restrictions aux sanitaires
mais bono mais rossi s'est exprimé on
écoute je pense aux blanchisserie qui
dépendent très directement de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration
je pense aux bouquinistes des quais de
paris puisqu'il ya moins de touristes à
paris aujourd'hui je pense aux arts de
la table puisqu'il y a moins de
restaurants ouverts je pense aux
graphistes nous allons ajouter au total
75 mille entreprises qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ce fonds de solidarité
elles sont 150 milles en bénéficier
aujourd'hui elles seront 75 milles
supplémentaires avec l'élargissement de
ce fonds de solidarité vous le disais à
l'instant vérité plutôt inquiet pour les
fleuristes par exemple est bien là donc
bruno le maire annonce un élargissement
du fonds de solidarité à 75 mille
entreprises supplémentaires
c'est une bonne mesure ça va suffire ça
va peut-être pas su alors c'est une
bonne mesure et ça ne va pas suffire
c'est une bonne mesure parce que nous
avons le devoir de soutenir ces gens de
toute façon le parti pris de la france
ça a été depuis le début de soutenir au
maximum les salariés et de soutenir au
maximum les entreprises c'est un choix
qui n'a pas été fait ailleurs un verre
aux états unis par exemple il n'y a
absolument rien donc c'est un choix très
fort qui a été fait par la france je le
soutiens j'ai participé à toutes les
réunions des économistes autour de bruno
le maire je pense que c'est vraiment le
bon choix
maintenant on est plus en mars en mars
les mesures fonctionnent et bien
aujourd'hui ce que demandent les
entreprises et ce dont elles ont besoin
c'est du chiffre d'affaires c'est de la
demande donc il faut le faire ce qu a
annoncé bruno le maire il a parfaitement
raison mais je reviens à ce que j'ai
tout à l'heure il faut aussi qu'on ait
des protocoles sanitaires qui permettent
à la vie économique de rompre elle ne
reprendra pas comme avant tant que nous
ne serons pas sortis de la crise tant
qu'on n'aura pas un vaccin mais il faut
au maximum que l'avionique reprennent
vous savez moi et moi ils m'écrivent
beaucoup ils m'interpellent beaucoup les
restaurateurs les fleuristes etc et ils
me disent mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est
très bien d'avoir du soutien sait très
bien qu'on nous aide mais nous ce qu'on
veut c'est travailler
on a travaillé c'est ce qui me disent
les restaurateurs envoyée et ça
d'ailleurs au passage dans notre pays on
a un certain nombre de gens notamment
sur la gauche de l'échiquier politique
qui dévalorise un peu le travail
eh bien il se trompe même politiquement
y compris ceux qui
prétendent être proche du peuple parce
que les gens du peuple moi ils me disent
on veut travailler
néanmoins vous avez aussi entendu le
débat qu'il y a autour du plan de
relance qui enfle sur la question des
contreparties à ce que ce n'est pas un
débat justifiée quand on voit bien ce
qui se passe pour air france pour
renault les contreparties elles sont pas
nécessaires non c'est un débat qui est
absolument injustifié qui sous-estiment
considérablement la gravité de la
situation
je les dis nous sommes dans la situation
économique la plus grave depuis huit
décennies
on va avoir énormément de faillites
d'entreprises on va le payer pendant
longtemps on va pas dire aux entreprises
à écouter on a une idée on baisse un peu
les impôts de production mais en
contrepartie il faut faire ça c'est
complètement absurde a pas d'aidé si ben
quand même pour certaines d'entre eux
bien sûr il y aura des effets d'aubaine
bien sûr on dépense trop d'argent public
bien sûr on va aider trop d'entreprises
parce que il ya aussi des entreprises
qui auraient dû faire faillite parce
qu'elles sont pas efficaces et on va les
soumettre
c'est ce qu'on appelle les entreprises
zombies bien sûr mais vous savez quand
on fait de la politique en ce moment on
fait toutes les décisions qu'on prend
elles sont mauvaises elles ont des
impacts qui sont négatifs
mais ce que l'on considère c'est que
d'autres décisions serait pire ou le
fait de pas prendre de décisions faites
moi ce serait bien on fait le moins pire
exactement c'est le tragique de la
politique aujourd'hui
et si on veut faire une politique
écologique moi ça fait dix ou quinze ans
que je pousse très fort pour qu'on
accélère sur l'écologie mais on fait des
vrais politiques écologiques on n'embête
pas les entreprises
on développe l'économie circulaire on
fait comme on va sans doute le faire en
europe je soutiens beaucoup ça une taxe
carbone aux frontières
on arrête au passage aussi de fermer des
réacteurs nucléaires parce qu'on peut
pas dire on va embêter les entreprises
d'un côté et la principale source
d'énergie propre
on la ferme donc on a une vraie
politique écologique mais on laisse les
entreprises se redresser et donc quand
on baisse les impôts de production ou
contrefaits des programmes
d'investissements d'avenir ou ce genre
de choses on ne demande pas de
contrepartie est-ce que vous jugez que
le plan de relance est équilibré quand
on considère et bien tout ce que cette
crise sanitaire va pousser vers la
pauvreté on l'a vu il va y avoir un
million de françaises et de français qui
vont être poussés dans la précarité en
plus ça on avait déjà 9 3 millions de
français qui vivent avec moins de 1000
63 euros par mois donc est-ce qu'il
fallait pas quand même plus injecter
vers cela si tu es il faut encore le
faire j'ai dis je
partage l'orientation du plan de relance
mais il ya une urgence sociale c'est pas
de la relance d'ailleurs c'est une
urgence sociale et donc en effet on voit
à nouveau une augmentation de la
pauvreté
on voit la réapparition de certains cas
de malnutrition en france laurent berger
a fait une proposition aujourd'hui qui
consiste à augmenter le rsa par exemple
j'y suis tout à fait favorable on voit
aussi des régions qui met en place
déchets qui donne des chèques restaurant
pour les publics fragiles
j'y suis très favorable donc je suis
d'accord avec ça je pense qu'il manque
encore un volet mais c'est pas de la
relance si vous laissez un volet urgence
sociale
bien sûr et dans ce contexte on a appris
aujourd'hui il ya un rapport qui va
faire du bruit que la suppression de l
isf et l'instauration de la flat tax au
début du quinquennat ont eu pour effet
de faire fortement augmenter les revenus
des 0,1 pour cent des français les plus
aisés
c'est la conclusion du deuxième rapport
de ce comité d'évaluation des réformes
de la fiscalité on peut pas le taxer
d'être de gauche en particulier voilà
deux partis pris parce que c'est quand
même un organisme qui est rattaché à
matignon qui s'occupe de ce rapport en
france stratégie qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
est ce que pour qu est ce que vous
pensez de ça ces mesures elles sont
acceptables quand on voit la crise dans
laquelle on est aujourd'hui oui
absolument pas ce que pour avoir une
bonne reprise économique on a besoin
d'avoir de l'investissement et pour
avoir de l'investissement on a besoin
d'avoir du capital je sais qu'en france
ce message chien qu'il ne passe pas mais
si vous taxer le capital
vous aurez moins de capital -
d'investissement moins d'emplois et
moins de salaire
taxer le capital c'est diminuer les
salaires à moyen terme et donc j'ai
soutenu la suppression de la partie
financière de liesse f
la flat tax sur les revenus du capital
parce que ce sont de bonnes mesures
économiques qui auront des impacts et on
le voit déjà d'ailleurs les entreprises
elles sont davantage de tours ce fameux
ruissellement et se ruent seulement ne
vient pas pour l'instant quand on voit
bien avec le contexte actuel est bien se
voit la pauvreté qui s'accroît oui non
mais le contexte actuel est absolument
exceptionnel mais c'est pas parce qu'on
a une situation économique grave qu'il
faut prendre des mauvaises mesures de
politique économique
vous ne m'aurez pas sur la démagogie fin
j'ai d'autres défauts si vous voulez
mais pas celui-là je me suis à titre
personnel même pas assujettis à l isf
donc vous voyez quelle est ma grandeur
d'âme je défends une mesure
populaire et alors qu'il ne me concerne
pas mais la pire des erreurs
ce serait de rétablir les sf parce que
c'est ça ce que je veux faire comprendre
ça se fera in fine et contre les
salariés allaient nicolas bouzou on va
aussi parler de votre livre l'amour
augmenter nos enfants et nos amours au
21ème siècle par tout simplement
pourquoi avoir décidé de parler d'amour
de famille de procréation on est loin de
la conversation convient d'avoir et de
vos sujets sur lesquels on vous connaît
vous savez j'avais beaucoup écrit sur le
travail j'ai sorti plusieurs ouvrages
sur le travail ces dernières années et
au fond dans la vie à deux grandes
choses qui sont importantes le travail
et la famille et l'amour voilà assez les
deux grandes choses qui nous qui nous
obsède
et puis j'ai aussi beaucoup travaillé
sur sur l'innovation sur les changements
technologiques et j'avais écrit
plusieurs ouvrages autour de l'idée
selon laquelle cette mutation
technologique
au fond elle faisait de nous des
consommateurs gâtés des consommateurs
infidèle et c'est vrai que nous sommes
devenus des consommateurs infidèle mais
nous sommes aussi devenus des employés
infidèle nous sommes devenus des
électeurs infidèle
la volatilité électorale a beaucoup
progressé et donc je me suis dit mais au
fond dans cette société où on refuse la
frustration ou on a ce qu'on veut en
permanence est ce que le couple qui est
la structure la plus rigide qui soit
vous êtes avec une personne c'est
toujours la même
en théorie vous de lui devait la
fidélité comment est-ce que ça peut
tenir comment est-ce qu'on peut encore
en fait être un reflet sur le monde de
volatilité merci de donner la conclusion
de mon livre
vous avez tout à fait raison je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez lu aussi nous sommes
d'accord mais en effet en effet ce qui
apparaît c'est que alors même qu'on
pourrait penser que tout est fait pour
détruire la famille entre guillemets
traditionnel parce que vous avez raison
il ya aussi des évolutions
technologiques et puis on a eu des
débats en france sur l'ouverture de la
pma pour les couples de femmes 1 le
débat qu'on a eu cet été on leur a
peut-être encore parce que le texte le
tactiquement
et puis un jour on aura peut-être un
débat sur la gpa c'est à dire la même
chose mais pour les pour les couples
d'hommes et donc on pourrait se dire
mais au fond tout ça est en train de
bouleverser la famille et un certain
nombre de deux
personne conservateur le plus grand
respect mais mon impression que ça
participe de l'écroulement du monde et
en fait non la famille elle tient bien
et nos familles aujourd'hui sont
essentiellement basée sur l'amour c'est
formidable et quand vous interrogez les
jeunes quand vous leur demandez mais au
fond qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous voulez
dans la vie ils nous disent mais nous ce
qu'on veut c'est vivre à deux avec
quelqu'un qu'on aime on veut avoir deux
enfants les élever et donc voyez des
choses assez classique
donc même s'il ya des divorces même s'il
ya de l'infidélité bon même si la
famille change même s'il ya des
homosexuels qui ont des enfants ce à
quoi je suis très favorable moi j'étais
très partisan à la fois du mariage pour
tous et de l'ouverture de la pma aux
couples de femmes je pense que ce sont
des évolutions absolument formidable
tout ça non seulement ne remet pas en
cause la famille mais mais au contraire
l institut l encre la famille d'amour
dans nos sociétés est ce que justement
n'est pas une société qui aujourd'hui
fait plus attention à cela on voit
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui disent eh
bien moi je vais aussi avoir ma sphère
de vie privée en même temps que le
travail peut-être qu'il ya 20 ans on
mettait beaucoup plus dans la carrière
que dans la vie familiale dans l'amour
dans la construction personnelle
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est une
évolution qu'on voit très clairement
mais je pense qu'il faut s'en méfier
surtout dans le contexte actuel c'est à
dire que ce qui nous ya qu une seule
chose qui nous sortira de la crise c'est
le travail
il n'ya que ça on peut faire de la dette
publique ont en fait énormément là
encore je pense qu'on a tout à fait
raison d'en faire on fait des gros plans
de relance j'entends dire d'ailleurs y
compris dans cette maison au sénat des
gens dire il n'aurait pas fallu faire
100 milliards d'euros du plan de relance
mais 200 milliards 1500 milliards gens
sérieux on peut tout dire évidemment
mais est évidemment un moment non mais
je veux dire c'est quelque chose que
marx l'a aussi d'ailleurs y compris dans
cette maison des gens qui se réclament
de la gauche devrait lire marx qui a
très bien expliqué le fait que in fine
et toute valeur elle provient du travail
et le travail
c'est quand même quelque chose d'aussi
de formidablement et heymans et c'est
quelque chose qui émancipe voyez l'amour
et le travail
être heureux dans son couple être
heureux dans son métier quand on a fait
ça on contribue à la société et puis
on a quand même réussi une bonne partie
de sa vie dans votre livre nicolas
bouzou vous défendez plutôt les applis
type kinder par exemple qui ont été
d'ailleurs des appliques en été pas mal
démoli par certain nombre d' enquête
dans celle de judith duportail à l'amour
sous algorithme qui montrait que thunder
manipule beaucoup nos rencontres nos
affinités pour vous vous pensez pas que
ça change quand même structurellement la
menant ces rencontres et non ça change
pas alors on a maintenant beaucoup
d'études sur les applications de
rencontre on voit que en effet elles
rendent plus fréquente les aventures
d'un soir ne suis pas un moraliste je
n'ai absolument rien contre les
aventures d'un soir et je pourrai pas
les critiquer mais ce que l'on voit au
delà de ça c'est que ça ne change pas
fondamentalement la façon dont on
choisit à un partenaire c'est très
hypocrite istres commerce quand on sait
qu'il ya des filtres dans les
applications vous faire rencontrer une
personne plutôt grave ou c'est vous qui
choisissez c'est pas une application
d'une part c'est vous qui choisissez
mais surtout la mauvaise nouvelle qu'on
oublier les sociologues qui critiquent
les applications c'est que ses fils
il existe dans la vie quand vous et moi
je suis d'une génération où on allait en
boîte de nuit croyais qu'il y avait pas
de filtre moi j'allais dans une boîte de
nuit à côté de mon université dans le
16e arrondissement c'était très cher je
peux vous dire qu'il y avait énormément
de filtre et la génération de mes grands
parents au bal musette il y avait des
filtres etc
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a
toujours existé mais vous savez là
encore les études le montrent bien
on rencontre des gens sur teen d'heure
bon il ya une mise en relation et après
que se passe-t-il quand on va au bar au
restaurant quand c'est possible en ce
moment c'est un peu plus compliqué on se
rencontre et on en revient au fond à des
relations qui sont des relations
extrêmement classique donc les
applications de rencontre moi je veux
dire si j'avais 18 ou 20 ans aujourd'hui
sans doute
j'utiliserai ses applications de
rencontre là vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure vous à nous avait parlé de du
fait que vous étiez favorable à la pma à
la gpa gpa et si bien dit vous en bien
sûr je suis ressent rapport mercantile
elle exactement 66 ans sans rémunération
delà de la mer qui donne ses ovocytes et
sans rémunération de
de la femme qui porte le bébé pas de la
merde ailleurs de la femme qui donne ces
nouveaux sites
parce que ce n'est pas la mer et sans
rémunération de la femme qui va porter
l'enfant et donc je le disais c'est tous
ces éléments et bien sont compris dans
la loi de bioéthique poursuit son chemin
au parlement
comment est-ce que quel regard vous
portez sur la façon dont ça se passe
cette fois ci parce que on est quand
même très très loin du climat
il y avait eu lors du mariage pour tous
de la manif devant tous il ya quand même
une évolution aussi je porte un regard
extrêmement positif alors à la fois on
voit les évolutions sociétales dans
l'est dans les sondages tout simplement
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
l'homosexualité typiquement est quelque
chose qui ne choque plus personne ce qui
n'était pas du tout le cas il ya 50 ou
60 ans je rappelle que l'homosexualité a
été dépénalisée dans un certain nombre
de pays européens dans les années 50 où
dans les années 60 donc c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement récent donc là
il ya une évolution incroyablement
positive et même quand on interroge les
gens sur la pma pour les couples de
femmes
ça choque encore un certain nombre de
gens mais en fait c'est vraiment rentré
dans les moeurs
et donc là encore on voit que le progrès
ça existe et que nos sociétés
elles vont vraiment dans le bon sens
dans le sens d'une plus grande tolérance
ni je trouve tout à fait admirable la
façon dont les débats et notamment le
débat parlementaire s'est déroulée sur
ces questions c'était un débat apaisé de
bon niveau et je trouve qui grandit le
débat public dans nos démocraties
il ya un autre débat au sein de ce débat
parlementaire sur la loi de bioéthique
dont on a beaucoup moins parlé au niveau
du grand public
et bien c'est tout le débat sur la
génétique et notamment le fait de
pouvoir par exemple améliorer couper nos
gènes argent parle d'autant que nous
venons d'avoir bien le prix nobel
voilà avec cette chercheuse française
qui vient d'algérie voilà le prix nobel
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de ce
débat parce que il ya aussi cette
crainte de pouvoir voilà de fer
bienvenue à gattaca pour y voir
améliorer notre patrimoine génétique et
ça bon pour le coup il ya encore
beaucoup de craintes
bien sûr ce débat de toute façon nous
leurrons puisque les évolutions
technologiques
nous nous emmène vers ça je suis
favorable à une sélection des embryons
et à une manie
pulation des embryons donc permise par
exemple par christopher kas neuf donc
l'objet du prix nobel de chimie
dans le cas de maladies très graves par
exemple dans la mucoviscidose
je suis tout à fait favorable à ce que
l'on puisse faire
alors soit une sélection des embryons
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec la
trisomie 21
soit une manipulation des embryons en
revanche je suis favorable à une
interdiction pour une sélection une
manipulation des embryons pour des
raisons par exemple esthétique soir
choisir les yeux de ses enfants
je pense que ça doit être complètement
interdite moi je crois à la régulation
je pense qu'on peut autoriser des choses
et je pense qu'on peut interdire des
choses on peut interdire des choses bien
sûr beaucoup et nicolas sûr d'avoir à
participer à cette émission et je
rappelle donc votre livre l'amour
augmenter nos enfants et nos amours au
21ème siècle